this is a combat patch which is what you
get once you've spent 30 days in country
I've been deployed three times all three
times with 101st twice to Iraq once to
Afghanistan and I'm about to deploy my
fourth time with the same division to
Afghanistan as a brand new chaplain I
was given the opportunity to come
straight into a filter Tillery unit
which is irregular for female chaplains
I've been in the military for
approximately two and a half years my
mom was actually in the Army as a
military intelligence officer
so following her path is kind of what I
I chose I decided to join the army
because it provided more opportunities
for me as a female in the Navy at the
time I was only gonna be allowed to be a
Surface Warfare Officer like my dad or
to fly some of the slower airplanes I've
been there the United States Army for
nine years and I joined right after 9/11
I was a single mother of two and I
decided that I want to do something else
to help my daughters I wanted to empower
them being females I wanted to show them
that they can do it they can do anything
that they wanted to do I can already
tell you from experience that a lot of
males do not like having a female in
charge of them a lot of males in the
combat arms and os's look at us like
we're the weaker sex you know and we
cannot perform to their standard as a
female still cannot be in the Special
Forces but I can still work alongside
them and so I was pregnant with my first
child
I wanted to get out it wasn't for me I
didn't really have I didn't really see a
future for myself in the military but
having her kind of opened my eyes to a
lot of the different things you know
that I'm providing for her through the
military my second pregnancy I worked in
a position where they didn't think it
was best that I continued on in that
role but I could still do that job being
pregnant I know when I'm trained to do
and I know how good I am at my job and
I'm
going to let any one person's ideas or
thoughts put me in a lower position so
I'm going to continuously push and push
and push until I get to where I want to
be we leave a lot of things behind our
families are the ones that pay the most
for us leaving them for fifteen months
nine months ten months my oldest
daughter is seven years old and in those
seven years I had spent maybe three of
them with her experiences while deployed
our experiences that are a lot of people
don't get a lot of people are not going
to see what we see so it's not about me
it's about those I'm serving now there's
just more opportunity to serve and I'm
just glad to fill that role personally
me I look at myself in the mirror and
I'm very proud of being Who I am as a
soldier
you